ladies and gentlemen today is the
greatest day of my life guests who just
got murdered guys I have a great idea
for a prank before Holt comes in I'm
gonna put ink on the podium where he
puts his hands I don't think he'll fall
for that I did how I haven't even opened
this yet I guess it's unrelated Captain
hold hates pranks this is gonna backfire
man ugh fine I'll tone it down I'll move
his Podium a foot to the left what he'll
be so angry okay five inches five three
three one one all right I'll move it a
half inch fine it's your funeral oh my
God
worst prank ever so stupid Hulk's not
even gonna notice good morning
you guys it the podium is
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off
what's this meeting about did someone
find my meatball sub hey we would never
have a meeting about that b you are
holding it oh I mean you can turn
meeting's not over dummy Terry said he
has some news from the office of
commissioner lunch what is that human
blister one now does she intend to
demote me even further or perhaps she'll
transfer me to the swamps of New Jersey
so I can Patrol the sinkhole where she
was spawned or it's possible the
announcement has nothing to do with you
okay thank you you're right maybe
Madeline wants to inform us all that
she's a juicing a what a choosen a
Korean toilet ghost lives in an outhouse
wraps her hair around your throat and
chokes you to death while you move your
balance you know what I will give you
six thousand dollars if the announcement
is she's at chukson okay everyone I have
some news so Madeline watch is a Korean
toilet ghost boring we already knew that
Madeline lunch is dead say what now wait
lunch is dead yeah the commissioner's
office just notified us no way that's
true as once says when she sees
deodorant I'm not buying it sir she's
dead oh Terry zombies can't die this is
some sort of scam if she were dead we
would be hearing the sounds of children
singing in the streets I don't know sure
you didn't believe it when we told you
the Disco Strangler died either and I
was right it was faking it maybe she's
alive why would once fake her own death
same reason she visits Mexico once a
year and sucks the blood from all the
goats for kicks look I don't know what
to tell you but she's dead but what do
you want to open up her coffin and check
for yourself
oh she's very dead Peralta where are we
with the black cab hold UPS well I got
this Jackie
oh all right have at it man nice jeans
Boyle those are surprisingly low-waisted
nice up here Gina I'm more than just a
piece of ass
not bad not bad an unlicensed cab driver
has been picking up tourists driver
takes the vix Down Under the BQE robs my
gum Point leaves him stranded
unfortunately because they're tourists
and our perp is not Caucasian we don't
have a clear idea of what he looks like
he was either Latino Arab or Mexican
either way very Muslim we'll go
undercover dress is Out of Towners hope
the prayer picks us up don't worry Sarge
let me know this guy
I can't believe I was just briefly
attracted to Boyle
adult parties Sergeant I believe they're
called orgies no look five
I met my wife at norgy well she was
leaving in orgy and we bumped into each
other on the street real meat cute thank
you for exhibiting exactly why this
meeting is necessary everyone here needs
some instruction on interacting with
grown-ups Sergeant why am I here I'm
always incredibly appropriate in high
school I was voted most appropriate ooh
self burn those are rare I shouldn't be
here either I'm fine at parties I just
stand in the middle of the room and
don't say anything hear the rules no
staring at your phones no rolling in two
hours late no sweatpants no jeans and no
shorts what about dress-up shorts for
instance the kind Jen Aniston I wear no
those are still shorts no shorts
and everyone bring a bottle of wine why
are there so many rules I mean next
thing you're gonna say is we can't be
late yeah that's like the first thing I
said
okay quick update on the Warren Street
break in security cameras caught a
picture of the suspect and guess what
that's right we got a hot purple alert
handsome man oh I'd like to bring that
guy to Justice we all would but
unfortunately police cornered him and he
shot himself in the face
hi thank you for that shockingly dark
update anything else uh yes
something I'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go
I'm bisexual all right I will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go Amy how long have
you known it's in seventh grade I was
watching Saved by the Bell and I thought
Zack Morris is hot and then I thought
Lisa Turtle also hot the fact that the
words Kelly and capacity didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now Charles
found out on the road trip and I was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep a secret for much longer bye Rosa
I mean not bye but bye I mean see ya I
mean have fun only having sex with men
just being a dudes left and right I just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes I am next do
you know Anne Heche I do oh I must say
this is going considerably better than
when I came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke I didn't mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent okay we have
time for one more question no no
absolutely not we're done
smart it was not tasteful and I believe
that's all I've got oh wait it's one
more thing Peralta gave me a note before
the meeting
ugh the penmanship is horrid but I think
it says ask if anyone has an anilment
it's announcements and we do wow what an
entrance Amy and I have some big news to
share
I'm pregnant we're pregnant
what the hell I thought you guys would
be more excited than that Charles you
didn't even faint I'm so sorry I'll try
it's not working somebody choked me on
it Rosa sorry we're so happy for you but
we also may be kinda already knew I mean
you didn't do the best job of hiding it
why have you been carrying that box
around so much I just love this box why
are you reading that newspaper it's two
days old I just love this issue hey why
are you wearing that hazmat suit I just
love this look okay fine so you all knew
we were pregnant good for you but I bet
you didn't figure out that we're having
twins
no not really it's one baby I just
needed to see Charles Spain but I got a
beam to boil too Santiago always tries
to finish my sentences and frequently
gets it wrong I do not and I am not
wrong you do it all the time no I was
going to say all the day long see
frequently wrong I dog sat for Scully
and he never thanked me Kelly was a real
handful wait I'm confused again Kelly
was a dog and we're two killers you'd
know that if you'd ever listened to my
podcast okay dude just relax don't tell
us to relax just because you're too nice
to have any pet peeves oh Terry's got
peeves Terry hates the way you always
make mouth noises when you eat meow meow
I'm Rosa I'm eating a croissant how's
this for a mouth noise you suck no you
suck as do you as do you and you I'm
here I'm here
you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier six years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy I was hard at work devising
a special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you Squad dismissed goodbye DS
[Music]
goodbye much
that's the butt bump goodbye Santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a Pete Townsend strum
all right that was terrible but it's
over now and I made it through goodbye
Leonard from Xerox what no no
the copy guys